this is what it would be like if Disney  Princesses or realistic makeup Aurora  would have some seriously clumpy mascara  and raccoon eyes after sleeping that law  note the dried drool as well  [Music]  had Mulan really tried to wipe her  makeup off in two swipes with her sleeve  it wouldn't have been that simple even  Ariel's waterproof mascara would have  been no match for a lifetime underwater  and her hair wouldn't have been  camera-ready  Belle's magenta lip gloss would have  smeared everywhere after making out with  the beats he would have ended up wearing  it - Jasmine's liquid eyeliner after a  windy tear inducing magic carpet ride  may have moved a bit and again her hair  wouldn't have been camera-ready  um princess Tiana's makeup definitely  wouldn't have been this perfect after oh  wait it's her wedding day yes yes it  would have Bridal makeup artist magic  [Music]